what's going on guys my name is David
homage and welcome back to the channel
today we're talking about something
we've definitely talked about in the
past but because it's been such a long
time since we've talked about it a lot
of things have changed so today we're
going to be talking about the surface
laptop 2 and all the problems that have
arisen over the last 18 months of owning
it
if you knew the channel thanks so much
for joining me
basically what we do here is talk about
technology and e-commerce related things
that you can pay for all these cool new
tech gadgets coming up in the series is
the brand new s20 ultra which is meant
to be shipped here maybe next Thursday
hopefully if the tracking is correct
which means the next video on this
channel right here will be the unboxing
of the s20 ultra if that's something
that interests you make sure you smash
that subscribe button
20:20 style and let's get on with this
video so previously I talked about this
laptop here and how good and phenomenal
it was and when it was seven months old
it was really really good
however as times progressed I've kind of
dented it a little bit it's worn it's
torn and it's still in pretty good
condition for 18 months old but it's not
in perfect condition so one of the
things I'm actually most concerned about
is I don't know if I'm going to be able
to depict this on the camera properly
but at the bottom just there well the
Alcantara keyboard is it's starting to
peel off so I'm a little bit worried
that in another six months another 12
months that whole keyboard is gonna
start peeling back and becoming a bit of
the next issue is again with the
Alcantara keyboard so for most people
you use your right hand to type and use
the trackpad and your left hand kind of
just naturally sits over the top of the
keyboard what's actually happened is
again I'm not sure if we're gonna be
able to show this because it's black but
the Alcantara has started to produce
kind of that old leather worn patina
texture it's sort of similar to how when
you get out the pool when your skin is
all wrinkled that's what's happened to
just that section of the keyboard there
so obviously where I rest my left hand
most the time for typing is exactly
where those markers don't show up now
I'm guessing because this is the black
version it's held up the best whereas if
I had the grey
version or I think it was the Marone
version it probably would have been a
lot lot worse
18 months down the track so I'm very
happy I bought the black version but
it's still something that he's gonna
start causing some problems very soon in
the near future
continuing an aesthetics point of view
it actually chips and dents pretty
easily I have mentioned before I did
drop this laptop and dented it in this
corner right here which was one of the
main dents that I kind of did it was
pretty bad and dented it quite nasty and
I was very happy that it didn't destroy
the screen but I do also have a chip
just there on the actual edge of the
display not entirely sure how that
happened
but it must have happened very fragile
II and without me knowing so from a
durability point of view something I'm
guessing relatively tough knocked it and
it has chipped and dented away at the
glass itself it hasn't destroyed the
screen so the screen is still 100%
intact no issues whatsoever so
eighteen-month down line few knocks few
bumps and a screen still in perfect
working the one thing that I did bring
up in my last video is if you click on
the center right there you can actually
feel and hear the click through the
screen so where the trackpad is and
where the screen connect is not too
solid it's not too durable and
definitely something to take note off if
you are picking up one of these second
hand or if you are picking one up on a
really good special now the surface
laptop three is out
moving on to performance and something
that's kind of progressively getting
worse
I think I guess it's not something I'm
really tracking too well but when you
leave it on your lap you do notice it
this laptop here overheats so much and
gets so so so hot the bottom of the base
being 100% aluminium it really heats up
very quickly and very rapidly when
you're doing some high-end graphics
intensive programs so this is the top of
the
change 3,300 laptop Australian dollars
there it has all the bells and whistles
in it but it still can't keep up with
some of the programs that I'm pushing
and does overheat quite a bit I feel
like as it gets older and as aspects
kind of tr8 against that everything else
and the interior gets a little bit dusty
because you can't actually clean it out
it starts to get hotter and hotter and
hotter so I do notice when I'm having it
on my lap when I'm wearing some shorts
that my legs do burn and I have to
actually be careful not to put it on the
skin and make sure it sits on the shorts
because it does get so hot now being
that this laptop is 18 months old
considering all those factors
predominantly being cosmetic and one
minor I guess a technical issue that may
only be specific to my laptop but I know
there's a few of you guys who have
commented down below on my last video
having the same issues with the
overheating they're not actually too bad
problems to 18 months down the track it
still runs incredibly fast the battery
life is still phenomenal the screen is
just as bright and just as good as it
was on day one from a performance point
of view and from a durability this
laptops gonna last me another five years
point of view I think I'm definitely on
a winner here so if you are looking at
buying a surface laptop to now almost a
year and a half after it's come out and
want a real serious review and a real
honest opinion I still think this is a
phenomenal laptop that will last you two
three four potentially five years
without any major issues as long the
Alcantara keyboard will be an issue so
unfortunately unless you get the surface
laptop 3 with the full aluminium body
you can't really do anything against
that you have to kind of deal with it on
the surface laptop - it only comes with
Alcantara keyboard so yeah take a little
bit of care I guess go for the black
option if you can and hopefully it will
last 2 3 4 5 years having said all these
issues that I have with it today 18
months
the trap that's all I have for you guys
today I just wanted to make a short
video on all the things that have
changed about this laptop because the
surface laptop to review is one of my
most watched videos on this channel
I think it's exceeded sixty 70 thousand
views which is phenomenal thank you so
much and I get a lot of comments about
what's changed since I've made that
video so hence why I wanted to make this
video today to just explain some of the
faults some of the technicalities
they're starting to show their true
colors eighteen months down the track
thank you so much for watching I hope
you enjoyed the video and as always I'll
see you next my